et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Annie genevar bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes député du
Doux secrétaire général des républicains
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Julien l'Écuyer de la Voix du Nord
bonjour Julien bonjour manage je ne
parle bonjour Annie genevaron on le voit
malheureusement ces derniers jours les
agressions se multiplient contre les
élus contre les forces de l'ordre contre
le personnel soignant va y revenir en
détail hier on conseille des ministres
Emmanuel Macron a parlé d'un processus
de décibilisation vous partagez ces mots
ah oui oui je pense que il faut
resibiliser notre société par
l'éducation beaucoup de jeunes sont
impliqués dans des actes délictueux on
voit bien que
les repères ont sauté pour autant qu'ils
étaient existé donc effectivement faut
qu'on réapprenne la civilité dans les
rapports du quotidien
parce que c'est devenu c'est devenu
vraiment de cette décibilisation là
[Musique]
politique le président des républiques
voilà je pense que la droite c'est
manifestée à cette occasion et depuis
longtemps
appel à la protection des élus
présentez vous comme le parti des élus
locaux comme pourquoi du coup avoir
participé hier
je ne crois pas quand le maire de
Saint-Brevin dénonce lui aussi la
récupération de l'extrême gauche c'est
le maire qui le dit lui-même n'a pas
participé à la manifestation donc je
pense que c'est un très mauvais procès
on a dans nos rangs énormément de mer on
a toujours eu le souci constant de
défendre les mers donc ça c'est une très
mauvaise querelle et je conseille fort à
nos adversaires politiques de la laisser
de côté parce que le combat il doit être
la France insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ou par des responsabilités
les termes de Jean-Luc Mélenchon que je
ne connais je ne commenterai pas je
pense que on ne peut pas prendre LR en
défaut sur le soutien qu'il a toujours
apporté aussi
ces élus locaux on a vu que Dominique
fort la secrétaire d'État avait proposé
un renforcement des sanctions un
alignement par exemple sur les sanctions
contre les forces les contre les
agressions vis-à-vis des forces de
l'ordre est-ce que vous êtes en accord
avec cette proposition alors
plusieurs remarques d'abord on voit bien
que le délitement de l'autorité publique
c'est un fait général on s'attaque
aujourd'hui au maire aux policiers ou
gendarmes aux pompiers à tous ceux qui
incarne le bien commun l'autorité
publique est aujourd'hui attaquée mais
je voudrais dire quand même à l'origine
des faits et c'est à mettre en relation
avec l'actualité du jour
la le gouvernement les pouvoirs publics
ont décidé de répartir dans l'ensemble
du territoire national des migrants
qu'ils ont été capable d'empêcher de
venir incapable de renvoyer dans leur
pays quand il n'était pas éligible à la
vieille faible non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que si le gouvernement et ça
fera le lien probablement avec un sujet
sur lequel vous allez m'interroger si le
gouvernement ne traite pas autrement que
comme il le traite la question
migratoire tout ça va mal finir parce
que ce qui s'est passé à Saint-Brevin et
d'ailleurs dans son audition au Sénat le
maire l'a dit il a été averti du jour au
lendemain de l'installation de de cette
structure devant accueillir des migrants
sans avoir été prévenu sans avoir eu le
temps de préparer les habitants de sa
commune et laisser se livrer à lui-même
pour mettre en oeuvre la chose
responsable de ce qui est arrivé
dans ce qui s'est passé et ce qui s'est
passé à
pourrais-je évidemment je le redoute
pourrait se passer ailleurs parce que
pour les Jeux Olympiques on est en train
de vider ou d'essayer de vider Paris de
ces migrants en les répartissant par
tout en France et ce sont les mères qui
seront en première ligne sur le sujet
donc je pense que au-delà de l'agression
insupportable du maire de Saint-Brevin
il y a aussi des circonstances qui font
que il faut bien regarder avant de
poursuivre cette politique de
répartition si on ne s'attaque pas au
sujet à la racine on y arrivera mais
vous dites tout ça va mal finir ça ça
peut finir comment pour vous bah tout ça
va mal finir parce que
vous vous ne pouvez pas demander au
territoire
d'accueillir sans que les choses soient
étudiées préparer qu'on est vérifié les
capacités d'accueil les capacités
d'intégration on déplace pas les gens
comme ça au gré de un des besoins de la
capitale ça veut dire d'autres
agressions voire pire
évidemment je ne le souhaite pas mais
si les choses sont faites comme elles
ont été faites à Saint-Brévin je redoute
que ça ne crée du conflit on parlait
immigrations
au Danemark avec Éric Ciotti pour
étudier la la façon dont le Danemark
gère cette cette question hier
interpellé sur le sur le sujet de
l'immigration le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gerald Darmanin estimait que les
propositions des républicains les deux
propositions de loi que vous avez
déposées mènerait un frais zip
migratoire qu'est-ce que vous lui
répondez
un frexit migratoire non je crois que
géra de Darmanin serait mieux inspiré de
regarder nous allons
déposer ces textes dans les heures qui
viennent il serait 12 ans
de quoi elles sont fait ses textes avant
de crier au loups
exposées partout et le fait que en effet
même au sein de la droite et même parmi
les centrices il y a une grande
interrogation autour justement de cette
remise en cause possible des traités
européens par la France
aujourd'hui ce qui je reviens du
Danemark comme vous l'avez dit la
politique est conduite là-bas est très
intéressante parce que elle démontre que
quand il y a une volonté politique il y
a des solutions qui existent l'eau sont
pas soumis à maltrateur l'autre atout du
Danemark c'est qu'en effet il a obtenu
de déroger à certaines dispositions des
traités européens et ça lui donne des
marges de manœuvre que nous n'avons pas
c'est très abusif de parler de frexit
c'était de sortie de la France de
l'Union européenne ça c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi j'ai envie de dire
monsieur
l'idée est que
on a besoin de l'Europe en matière de
politique migratoire c'est évident la
protection des frontières extérieures de
l'Europe est indispensable et il faut
travailler à l'évolution des politiques
migratoires des réponses à l'immigration
qui touche tous les pays l'Union
européenne il faut travailler ces
questions au niveau européen personne ne
dit le contraire aux républicains
simplement nous disons
lorsque les intérêts fondamentaux de la
France
sont menacés et pour autant que la chose
soit bien circonscrite il est possible
de déroger donc vous voyez c'est quand
même pas tout à fait la même chose et là
il appartiendra effectivement de
regarder dans quelles circonstances ces
intérêts fondamentaux peuvent être
menacés mais je trouve que c'est
irresponsable de la part de Gérald
Darmanin d'évacuer
comme ça par une outrance le frexit
c'est une outrance et un mensonge
un point capital qui redonnerait aux
politiques français la capacité de
décider de reprendre en main leur
souveraineté migrate vous allez
peut-être me dire si c'est aussi une
outrance de la part du député tommel
ménagé qui disait que les républicains
devraient payer au rassemblement
national des droits d'auteur étant donné
que beaucoup des propositions que vous
faites sont en fait des propositions qui
avaient déjà été faites par Marine Le
Pen durant la campagne présidentielle ou
même bien avant
alors moi je serai tenté de dire c'est
plus le débat aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut c'est répondre à un
problème grave vous assumez vous assumez
d'avoir les mêmes propositions en 2017
Éric Ciotti aujourd'hui président du des
républicains déposent une proposition de
loi très dense et très complète
moi je vais pas dire ou rassemblement
national tient en 2020 quand vous
déposez vos propositions vous les avez
empruntés à Éric sciotique donc tout ça
n'a aucun sens ça c'est de la petite
politique moi je dis simplement que le
rassemblement national depuis un an
qu'il a des députés n'a déposé aucun
texte sur les politiques migratoires
aucun texte et madame va pas attendre ni
le gouvernement ni le rassemblement
national pour faire nos propres
propositions donc ce cet accusation est
non seulement elle est ridicules mais
surtout elle témoigne du peu de
considération que ce sujet mériterait
mais sur quoi ils vont aboutir vos
textes ici au Sénat on a appris que les
centrices allaient déposer leurs propres
textes donc ils sont peut-être pas
enclins à voter les vôtres on imagine
mal l'ensemble de la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée nationale
en tout cas l'aile gauche votée vos
propositions de loi est-ce qu'ils vont
paraisser être morte
alors vous savez l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas de majorité absolue donc sur ce
texte
a priacte des atermoiement du
gouvernement je présente un texte je le
retire je le saucisse sonne je le retire
finalement je vais peut-être le
présenter devant
tant d'indécision alors même que la
situation
s'emballe puisque on aura accueilli près
de 500 000 nouveaux étrangers sans
compter les irréguliers
entre les demandes d'asile les mineurs
non accompagnés la délivrance des titres
de ces jours 500 000 personnes je
rappelle que c'est presque le double que
en 2012 lorsque Nicolas Sarkozy quitte
l'Elysée donc devant à la fois tant
d'indécision et une décision et une
situation qui devient très urgente nous
on a dit on avance et on laisse à Boyer
les uns et les autres
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas condamné à
trouver un chemin quand même avec le
gouvernement autour de cette question
pour au moins avancer nous on dit il y a
un chemin c'est ces mesures elles ont
été très calibrées très étudié très
travaillé et pas seulement au sein des
républicains mais avec des
constitutionnalistes avec des hauts
fonctionnaires avec
donc ces mesures on les a éprouvées on
est allé au Danemark pour voir ce que
ces mesures donnaient c'est un
gouvernement
social-démocrate qui les a qui les met
en oeuvre aujourd'hui c'est à dire la
gauche danoise
jusqu'à quand la gauche de notre pays
elle est bien pensant de toute de tous
horizons continuons
les yeux moi je dis s'il y a quelques
sujets qui mériteraient
véritablement de se mettre autour de la
table et de voir ce qui est efficace
c'est celui-là vous voyez mais est-ce
que je sais ce que parce que Elisabeth
borne a demandé à Gérald Darmanin de
d'entamer les consultations avec les
différents partis pour qu'un texte soit
présenté au mois de juillet est-ce qu'à
l'heure actuelle les républicains
discutent avec Gérald Darmanin de ce
sujet non sur les textes que nous
déposons il n'y a pas eu de discussions
et sur le site du gouvernement formalisé
est-ce que vous êtes en train de
discuter avec Gérald Darmanin sur le
texte du Gouvernement plus pas de
discussion formalisée pas de discussion
prévue moi ça ça appartient au
gouvernement mais vous vous êtes
secrétaire général du parti vous n'avez
aucun rendez-vous fixe absolument aucun
aucun rendez-vous et je pense que il y a
matière à discuter vous savez qu'une des
lignes rouges pour nous c'est la
régularisation des métiers en tension ce
que le Medef ne demande pas le Medef dit
clairement ne prétendez pas que c'est
nous qui le demandons nous nous disons
attention c'est un signal donné vous
savez
l'immigration Danemark s'est effondrée
savez-vous pourquoi
tout simplement parce que
tout signe de fermeté est parfaitement
compris dans les pays émetteurs de
population d'immigration mais tout signe
de l'action
également et donc nous nous disons en
créant ce droit au métier en tension on
crée un droit opposable on crée un appel
d'offres ce sont des régularisations
possiblement massives et ça ce n'est pas
possible dernier petit question sur le
sur le sujet qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de la photo du JDD où on voyait
Bruno Retailleau Olivier Marleix et Eric
cioti pour décrire ce projet de loi
immigration alors que vous aviez
participé à la réunion fixant ces deux
propositions de loi est-ce que vous avez
pensé comme Diane Tell a si j'étais un
homme ou bien où sont les femmes de
Patrick Juvet
c'est une question légitime pour ne rien
vous cacher je les avais alerté je leur
avais dit et
il n'écoute pas alors vous savez les
choses progressent lentement chez nous
mais le progresseront on va parler de la
proposition de là du groupe qui vise à
abroger la réforme des retraites le
texte doit être examiné par l'Assemblée
nationale le 8 juin ce que pour vous le
débat doit avoir lieu
moi je pense que le débat a eu lieu le
débat a eu lieu et Dieu sait qu'il a été
enflammé les insoumis n'ont empêché
qu'elle Assemblée nationale l'examen du
texte n'aille à son terme aujourd'hui
ils veulent remettre le couvert
en disant nous nous voterons ce texte
mais enfin le départ le débat il s'est
donc il faut pas recommencer lui joint
moi je pense que tout a été dit tout ce
qui pouvait être dit sur le sujet a été
dit vous savez mon point de vue moi j'ai
toujours considéré que et je n'ignore
pas toutes les difficultés que ça pose
et toujours considérée qu'il fallait
réformer les retraites pour pérenniser
la retraite par répartition et on a
beaucoup amélioré le texte on l'a rendu
moins dur plus progressif ça a été notre
contribution je tiens à le rappeler
quand même parce que dans ce Brouage
général on oublie de dire qui a fait
quoi alors les membres du groupe on
plaidait cette cette cause et ça reste
une difficulté puisque certains membres
de votre groupe risque de de voter si si
les 200 parlementaires de droite que
nous sommes
si tu une petite c'est une petite
vingtaine qui a voté la notion de
censure et qui n'aurait pas voté ce
texte de loi donc il faut remettre les
choses
encore une fois ça va jusqu'au débat
dans l'hémicycle qu'il y ait beaucoup de
de parlementaires LR qui qui est piscine
ou aquaponée me disait un député LR je
crois que la situation est un peu
différente dans la mesure où ce texte de
présenté par le groupe liotte on le sait
n'a que peu de chance d'aller à son
terme c'est pas la même donc
peu de chance d'aller à son terme même
s'il y a un vote même si je pense que la
difficulté vous me posez la question à
moi la difficulté elle est surtout du
côté du gouvernement parce que la raison
de
chez vous est-ce que vous savez combien
de députés les républicains sont prêts à
vos tests
vous savez qu'on a une tradition au sein
de notre groupe qui est la liberté de
vote donc je pense que quelques
personnes voteront c'est combien
quelques personnes on n'a pas pointé
mais c'est la vingtaine de la motion de
censure c'est moi c'est plus je suis pas
certaine que les vins qui ont voté la
motion de censure veut très ce texte
précisément parce que il est
il n'a pas d'avenir ce texte donc
certains
probablement voteront conformément au
vote qu'ils ont eu sur le le premier
texte le projet de loi du gouvernement
mais peut-être certains
la majorité a raison de soulever
l'inconstitutionnalité de ce texte
moi je pense que ça pose en effet une
question
il me semble que ça n'est pas tout à
fait conforme à ce pourquoi est fait le
Parlement le Parlement veut une loi ou
adopte un texte de loi si maintenant les
propositions de loi visent à annuler les
lois qui viennent d'être votées je me
dis qu'il y a un risque effectivement de
dévoiement de l'institution
parlementaire
autre sujet qui va intéresser
l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est le drame
de Roubaix avec trois policiers tués
dans un accident le président Emmanuel
Macron président une cérémonie d'hommage
nationale pour les trois policiers
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous inspire
ce drame
il m'inspire comme à tous les Français
une très grande tristesse et beaucoup de
colère aussi parce que
ces trois jeunes gens qui avaient leur
vie devant eux qui accompagnait une
personne qui était en détresse ont été
victimes hélas d'un phénomène de plus en
plus courant c'est à dire de gens qui
conduisent sous l'effet de droguer
d'alcool
l'actualité nous en a fourni plusieurs
exemples absolument tragiques est-ce
qu'il faut renforcer les sanctions
contre ces conducteurs je pense qu'il y
a un sujet il y a un sujet de drogue il
y a un sujet violence routière nous
avons à nos collègues Eric Roger à
l'Assemblée nationale qui travaille à
une proposition de loi
sur quoi précisément
et bien une proposition de loi sur la
création d'un homicide routier quand il
s'agit de conducteurs sous l'emprise de
substances
drogue de stupéfiants et d'alcool parce
que c'est vraiment insupportable et puis
il y a le sujet vous allez déposer
prochainement du coup il l'a déposé hier
ou avant-hier je crois mais il y a un
sujet de drogue énorme immense qui
nourrit la criminalité dans tout le pays
c'est pas seulement la violence routière
c'est aussi une criminalité organisée
qui est en train de gangrener non
seulement les villes il n'y a pas que
Marseille mais également les territoires
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
c'est le combat nourricier c'est
vraiment
ne fait pas assez ça a été c'était la
grande cause de Bovo ces dernières
années
moi vous savez quand ça ne va pas je le
dis mais je pense que en matière de
lutte contre la drogue
c'est un combat très difficile je ne
doute pas qu'il soit qu'il soit mené au
plus haut au plus haut niveau de l'État
maintenant on voit bien que dans notre
pays la question de la sécurité publique
se pose désormais partout
on peut reboucler avec la question de
l'immigration beaucoup de fées
délictueux sont liés à l'immigration
irrégulière ça a été dit à Paris un fait
sur deux
de délinquance donc là on voit bien
qu'il y a tout à reprendre et avec des
mesures plutôt que de pousser des cris
d'or frais sur les textes qu'on va
déposer notamment les modifications
qu'on pourrait apporter à la
Constitution il vaudrait mieux
s'interroger sur la pertinence de ces
mesures dans le sujet qui nous occupe
une dernière question je viens
oui autre drame celui de du meurtre
d'une infirmière à Reims attaqué par un
individu qui était connu pour souffrir
de troubles sévères alors il avait
bénéficié d'un non-lieu en 2022 pour
irresponsabilité pénale est-ce que la
justice a failli
ce qui est en cause dans cette terrible
affaire c'est aussi la capacité dans
laquelle nous sommes de traiter les
personnes ayant besoin de d'une prise en
charge psychiatrique moi je l'ai vu
quand j'étais mère il y avait des
personnes dont je craignais qu'elle ne
puisse se montrer violente j'avais fait
des signalements à plusieurs reprises
mais l'encadrement psychiatrique n'était
pas suffisant en plus s'ils prennent pas
leur médicament qui qui peut
nous mettre à l'abri de ces de ses actes
personne n'est là pour vérifier aucune
mesure de surpris qui avait été
prononcée à son à son enfant
hélas alors que en tout cas c'est ce qui
se disait ce matin dans les médias la
mère de l'individu avait pressenti qu'il
pourrait passer à l'acte donc là il y a
sans doute à déterminer les pour les
analyser pour éviter leur reproduction
la chaîne des des
responsabilités mais de façon générale
on a plus de psychiatre nos hôpitaux
fermeuses psychiatriques fermes des lits
faute de soignants
de psychiatrie responsable indispensable
dans toutes nos villes nous avons des
malades psychiatriques merci Julien la
Une de La Voix du Nord on en parlait un
dernier hommage de la nation aux trois
policiers tués c'est à la Une de votre
journal ce matin merci Julien merci
beaucoup merci
ce matin on passe tout de suite au club
des territoires